それからストレスの仕組み
で まあできるだけ早く進めようと思います
もう楽しくやっている
成功している ストレスなんか感じたこともないというふうに人々もいますよ
世の中にはね そう言っちゃうと
この楽しくやっているというのも
大成功している人々いるんですよ
世界で もうものすごいもう年商何百億とかいう人々なんかは
ものすごい頑張っていて
ストレスなんかは感じたことがないと平気で言うんです
そうなると 貪瞋痴があってもストレスが溜まらない場合もあるのか？という疑問が出てくるんです
仏教に攻撃かけられますよ
私は言ったでしょ？貪瞋痴はもう悪いと
ではもう大社長 大会社の社長とか
もう年商がもう億単位でっていう人々はどうでしょうかと
ストレス感じてないでしょうと
でも あの ものすごい明るい女性の方がいたんですね
何さんでしたっけ？全く真っ白いの
鈴木園子さんなんですね
で ほとんど一日に時間
3時間しか寝てなくて
いくつかの会社を随分もうテキパキとやってね
もうもう成功ばっかしでしたでしょうね
人生は成功一筋でしたからね
でも かなり体が壊れてたでしょ
どこかでね もう人の前で倒れたりもしましたし
だから貪瞋痴があると思う
ストレスは溜まります
問題は だったら私たちも同じくもう辞めたくなる気持ちあるはずですよ
それがなかったんですよ
それって何なのかと 突然体が壊れて死んじゃったんですけど
別に死ぬぐらいの年ではなかったし
だから寿命は縮んだんですよ
だから私が言うことは別にもう間違ってることになってないんです
貪瞋痴で生きてると やっぱり報いは溜まるんです
溜まって寿命が縮めるんです
そういう方々の問題は
仕事を途中では辞めない
うまくいきます 流れに
人よりはもう何百人ぐらいの仕事もする
そのめげずに諦めず 腰を上げずにできたことって何なのかっていうことは
別に考えても構いません
それで次に行きます  これから全くなんか話が変わったような感じがするかもしれませんだけど
有名なことわざがありますね
白ラクダが針の穴を通すという
これがあの まあ皆様ご存知ですからね
聖書に出てくるあの え？ ラクダが針の穴を通すのとはラクダがやって
あ なるほど じゃあ通るにしましょう
ラクダがやってることになるんですね
それからその問題は出ると思います
まあ一応 まあその時その時直しています
で これがあの聖書にある話で
この金持ちに天国に行くっていうことはね
あのラクダが針の穴を通るぐらいの可能性であると言っていますけど
それは無理ということのために言ってますけど
私が逆に言いたいのは
世間はそんなことをやってるんだと
みんな これは世間の生き方
聖書にしたっても 世間の生き方言ってるんです
あれ あのたとえでみんな天国に行くことを考えてるんじゃなくて
全く別な生き方をしてるんだから
あなた方には天国に行くということは
もうラクダが針の穴を通るぐらいのもんやと
欲も期待して待っていなさいという話なんです
天国に行けると だから道が違うんだそうと聖書でも言いたがっているんです
それは聖書の話で だからキリスト教も同じことを言ってるわけじゃないんです
しかし 仏教的に説明するために
この例えを変えてみます
私は太いロープを針の穴を通すですね
その場合は  穴にです  穴に
うん あの聖書みたいに全く無理不可能ということは言いたくはないんです
だから ラクダの代わりに私は太いロープを持ってくるんです
かなり太いロープを細い針の穴を通してみようかなと我々はやってるんです
それは仏教的な見方ですよ
だから聖書の見方よりは結構明るいんです
ラクダのたとえがくると
もう待っていなさいと
あんたが天国に行けるかという態度なんです
行けるわけないんじゃないかと
はい まあそんなに難しい話ではないんだから
次に行きます それで説明に行きます
こんな太いロープをあれぐらい細い針ではね
で これがストレスの仕組みなんです
これ自体は だから結果はどのようになるのでしょうかと
で 次にそれでストレスは引き起こすんです
これ 例えの説明に入ります
ロープというのは我々の心
結構太いんです かなり太くて線が多すぎです
これで穴を通そうと思っちゃうと
もううまくいかないんです
その状態で生活して仕事をしているんだから
ストレス溜まるんです
それで次に行きます 針の穴とは現在行っている仕事
行為なのです これで私は針の穴と言ったのは
今私たちはやっている
行っている行為 仕事 何かするとストレス溜まるでしょ？遊ぶとか寝るとか会社に行くとか
もう何でもいいんです
24時間我々は何かしている
その時はストレス溜まる
ですから 何かをするということは
この針の穴を通ることなんです
これ 針の穴を通ることで
持っているロープはちょっと太すぎ
線がありすぎ 通らないんですよ
そこでまあ一部を通るかもしれません
通って引っ張っても引っかかるんですよ
それで では違う線で試してみようかなと
で また一部を通って引っ張ろうとするんだけど
また引っかかるんですね
だから通ったこと通ったんですよ
ロープの二 三線 二 三本でも穴から通ったら
穴通ったら通ったことになります
しかし 結構嫌なんですね
あの結果は あのロープを見事に針の穴を通ってるんだったら気分がいいんです
でも  1本2本だけ線が通ってはいるんだけど
まあこれでは通ったことにはならないんですね
結局は気分がいいわけじゃないんです
我々の仕事のやり方はそういうやり方なんです
それであの さらに説明します
集中して仕事に取り込まない
だからこれはロープをっていうのは我々の心でしょ
太すぎということは 集中してきちんと細くして
穴に通るような感じにしてないんです
だから我々日常生活でやるにはやるんだけど
集中して真剣にやらないんですね
仕事は それでやりたい
やりたくない できる できない
うまくやりたい 成功させたい
失敗するかも つまらない
面白い 無意味だ そんないろんな感情があるんですよ
これはロープの線なんですよ
これはロープの線なんです
あ この仕事やりたいと思った同時に
やっぱりやっぱりやりたくないと
またこれ あ これならできる
もしかするとできないんじゃないかとかね
ごちゃごちゃ考えるんですよ
やるにはうまくやりたい
でも失敗するでしょうと
それでこんな仕事っていうのは面白くない
まあでも面白くない 面白いでしょうとまた考えたりする
どちらですかと 本人は面白いか面白くない
わからない 時は時々面白いと思ったり
時々面白くないと思ったり
いろんなこのこんなこと頼まれたっても
これ責任重大だと思ったりするでしょ
もうやる気がなくなっちゃうんですよ
負けたくないという気持ちになっちゃうと
もうやけになるでしょうに
負けたくないと思ったっても
でも負けるかもねと思っちゃうと
もう落ち込んじゃうんです
それでこれやってみんなに認めてもらおうと
でも出したところで却下されるかもと思っちゃうと
また落ち込む 認めてもらおうと思っちゃうと舞い上がりますけど
それで仕事できなくなります
さらに考えちゃうと もしかするとこれ却下されるでしょうと思っちゃうと
また落ち込んだりする
で 評価されるかもということもある
やる気は出ない 等の線で心は太すぎです
こんな気持ちで仕事をすると
ストレス溜まるのは当たり前でしょうに
ストレス溜まらなかったら不思議なんです
だから世間で言うんですよ
人間にはストレスというのは好きもんだと
こういうことですよ 心のロープが太すぎ
穴の大きさと比べると
まあわかることですから
誰でも 誰にでも見覚えあるでしょう
じゃあ次に行きます こういう状態は仏教用語ではもうちゃんと用語があります
いくらかこの欲 欲っていうのは認めてもらおうではないかと思っちゃうと
それは欲じゃないんですね
これでうまくいくかもしれませんと
これで儲かるかもしれませんと思ったら欲でしょうし
負けたくないうんうん思っちゃうと怒りでしょう
却下されるでしょ 思っちゃうと怒りでしょう
で 無知 できっこないでしょ
こんなのは と思っちゃうと無知なんです
こんな責任 私一人に任せちゃったら
それ無知なんです で 嫉妬
負けたくないと思っちゃうと
もうかなり嫉妬が働いている
で 恨み 高慢 それで混乱
うわつき 後悔 困惑 次は何でしたっけ？怠惰
疑 すべて不善生諸として仏教で書いているものです
私たちはそういう感情でもう仕事に取りかかるんです
だから穴を通るのは 1本か間違ってます
1本か 2本ぐらいですよ
あんな感情いっぱいあっても穴は通りませんよ
だから線２ ３本で通るんです
残りは引っかかります
これまたまた引いて別な線を通してみようとするなんです
引いたではなくてね そこで太いロープを２ ３
本通してから もう行ったぞ
行ってないんだと それで別な線を通してみたりする
そうやって我々は大体仕事っていうのは何回やりやり直すでしょう
結構時間なくなりますよ
やり直せば直すほどストレス溜まるんです
ロープの引っかかることはストレスというものです
この感情が引っかかるところはストレスということですね
それがストレスの仕組みです
で 次にまたさらに説明します
一つの行為をするとき
それに反対の別な感情が裏に潜む
だから認めて これでは認めてもらうんだぞと決めているんだけど
反対の感情がもしかすると却下されるということは潜んでいるんです
これはヒット商品で儲かりそうと思っても
もしかするとヒットしないかもと
逆の感情は必ず潜んでいるんです
潜んだ感情が意識になると
表面の感情がまた潜む
それは何で言いますかというと
あの針の穴を通る線が決まっているんです
だから必要な機能するものは表に来ます
機能しないものは下裏でいて邪魔するんです
行為するとき 感情がルーレットのように回転するのです
だから我々の感情がずっとルーレットみたいにグーッと回っているんです
だからうまくいかないんです
手でボールを投げようと思ったら
手でぐるぐるぐるぐる回りながら回しながら投げたっても
もう当たらないでしょうに
それで仕事をこなしてもストレスが溜まるのです
したがって 楽しいことをしてもストレスが溜まってしまうのです
ですから 何やっても感情がもうごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃもう回転しているんだから溜まっちゃうんです
で 次 で わかりやすく言えば優柔不断ということです
しかし 俗世間でいう優柔不断と違うんです
これが 俗世間の優柔不断というのは
何か決断力がないぐらいの話ですけどね
そんなもんじゃなくて
微妙にものすごい力強い優柔不断なんです
だからもういい加減言葉使ったんで作ったんです
感情錯乱 もう日本語でもないんですけど
まあしょうがないんです
優柔不断じゃなくて これ感情錯乱
いつも感情錯乱状態で仕事してるんです
もっと皆様知っている言葉で言えば
これ本音と建前なんです
それはちょっと近い言葉なんです
しかし この場合も本音は何なのかと本人も知らない
俗世間でいう本音建前の場合は知っているでしょうに
我々は本音を言う時は
建前を言う時は本音はちゃんと知ってますよ
俗世間では でもこの場合は自分の本音って何なのか
自分でも知らない あんた仕事やりたいんですか？あるいはやりたくないんですかと
求めて欲しいんですかと
あるいは求めて欲しくないんですかと
どちらか本人もわからない
学校に行きたくない子供と同じなんです
あんた本当に学校に行きたくないんですかと
あるいは行きたいんですか？どちらですかと
わからないんですよ 感情錯乱状態なんです
だからこの状態でストレス溜まるんですよ
だから本音と建前なんですけど
本音って何なのかとわからないんですね
ルーレットで回るんだから
ある時はやっぱりやりたい
やっぱりやりたくない
表に出てくることばっかり言ってるんです
で まあこういう状態でなければいけないんですよ
糸なら針を通すんですよ
ロープではダメです センスは決まっている
糸の場合は 心の場合も
必ず必要な感情だけ機能するならば良いのです
だから我々は太い気持ちで仕事をするんじゃなくて
細い気持ちでやればいいんです
やるかやらないかどちらか
やると思ったらやる やらないと思ったらキレさったり
やめる 時々会社が辞めたい
でもやっぱりまずいな
これは とかね でも辞めたい
まあまずいんだからやっぱり仕事するとか
それでもうごちゃごちゃだからね
はっきり決めればいいんです
会社辞めるか続くかと
はっきり決めたら 会社辞めたところでホームレスになったっても
ストレスはたまりませんよ
明るく生きてられます
俺が辞めてやったぞと
で 今はお金ないんだから
もうホームレスでいるんだぞと
別に不幸じゃないんです
だから気持ちは細くした方がいいんです
えーと それ これ解決解消への道ですからね
はい 次 で 刺繍の種類によって糸の種類も変わるが
全ての針は通ります 全ては針を通ります
かな 何ですか？ちょっとまあ
それでいいですか あの
いろいろ刺繍の種類ありますよ
何を縫いかっていうことで
時々あの革でもね 縫ったりするでしょう
だからそのものによって選べる選ぶ糸が違うんです
服を縫う時 あの革カバンを縫う時
使う糸で服を縫ったっても
もううまくいかんでしょうに
だからいろいろ種類の糸があるんです
しかし 糸の特色は針の穴を通るんです
糸だから 必ずも だから糸っていうのは心の例えだから
そのその仕事に必要な感情は何なのかっていうのは決まってるんです
仕事を別に それ以外のものは全部邪魔なんです
恋の場合も 心と組み合わせる心象は決まっているのです
感情錯乱状態なら 糸はロープほど太くなっているのです
糸に編み込まれてないものだから
かえって心が弱くなっているのです
だから いらん感情も過ぎてるんだから
弱い心ですよ だから 糸に必要な線だけだったら
糸が強いんです だから仕事別ですから
糸っていうのは時々この手術する時も糸で縫う時ありますよ
体の中でも糸で縫いますよ
きちんとこの臓器をしっかりつけてくれますよ
でも その糸は 2 3週間で溶けてしまうんです
だから弱い糸とは言えませんよ
仕事はちゃんとしてくれるんだから
しかし 体の前の場合はもう我々動いたりするんだから
もうナイロン製やらなんとかでもう抜いておくんです
それが消えます それで傷跡が治ったら
医者が糸を全部取ってしまうんですね
だから 仕事によって糸の種類があります
だからって糸が弱いわけじゃないんです
糸は適しているだけなんです
だから絹の糸を使うか
ナイロンの糸を使うか
もう木綿の糸を使うか
それは仕事によりますよ
で その糸に余計なもの入っていると役に立たない
それは糸の論理ですよ
そんなのは単純でわかると思います
本当は仏教心理学部ではものすごい難しいところですよ
これちょっともうタイトルだけ言ってるんですけどね
はい 次に行きます 心は針のようにはっきり決めているならば
良いことであれ 悪いことであれ
何の躊躇もなくストレスもなく行うことができる
適切な意図を選んじゃえば
針に通るんですよ だから
自分がやる行為は良いことであろう
悪いことであろう うまくできるんですよ
なんでそれ書いたかというと
この園子様やら またすごい大成功している人々も
もうちゃんと意図を選んでいるんですよ
前に例に出た鈴木園子さんも
まあ自分で起業を起こしてもう大成功を収めるんですよ
信じられないほど収入を得て成功しているんです
なぜかというと あ 疲れた
なんでこんな仕事をしなくちゃいかん
そんな余計な意図はないんですよ
労苦になってないんです
意図でいるんです はっきりともう儲かるんだぞということで
だから何のことなく意図を通るんです
だから この心が意図の状態でやる感情が必要な感情だけでやると
どんな仕事も成功する
それでいい仕事も悪い仕事もある
それで仕事に必要な感情が割り込むと
必要でない感情が割り込むと問題なのです
それで成功はしなくなっちゃうんです
で 成功を収める方法っていうのは
この優柔不断がないと
ただそれだけなんです
えーと 次は で ちょっとした例なんですよ
盗むということをしたければ
欲だけやれば十分ですよ
成功します 難しくないんです
それで殺したければ 怒りだけやれば殺せますよ
自分の目的は成功します
それはもう悪い例で見せたんです
行動を引き起こすために必要な意欲
意志 思考 集中力などの共通する要因と合わせれば実行できるのです
例えば 盗みたいんだったら
欲とこの下 黒い文字で書いているものと合わせるんです
それが共通です 良いことにも悪いことにも
下書いてるものは欲と合わせると堂々と盗めますよ
銀行強盗でも何でもできる
そこで殺したければ 怒りとこの下の共通感情を合わせれば
もう堂々と殺せるんです
それでこの枠の中で書いているものを読んでみてください
これでいいのかと思っちゃうと
もう優柔不断なんです
これを疑という真相なんです
これが入ると欲が揺れるんです
疑が入っちゃうと しかし
欲が揺れていい人間になるわけじゃないんです
疑自体も悪いんです 記録を取る
こんなことをして 私はもう記録取ってやる
すると慢なんですね そうするとまた感情が揺れちゃうんです
それで失敗すると で 障りになって
結果としてストレスです
それでストレスたまるんです
盗むのは本当に良くないな
悪いな やっぱり でも盗まなく盗まなくてはいけないということで盗みに入ると
成功してもストレス溜まってるんです
10万円取ったんですけど
あれは本当におばあちゃんですからねと思っちゃうと
おばあちゃんかわいそうでしたとかね
で そういうことでストレスになるんです
だから この何て言いますか
血も何もない 残虐 残酷な悪人とか言ってるでしょうに
でもそういう人々は見事に成功はしてるんですよ
学校に行って何人も刺すとか
で そこで裁判でわかるでしょ
後悔ではなくて 反省は全然ないんです
だからストレスないんですよ
今 私はあえて悪い例を出して説明しているんです
その方が理解しやすい
なぜならば 禅ということを全然知らないんだから
貪瞋痴しか知らないんだから
で 皆様方はなんでそんなに犯罪を起こさないのかというと起こせないんですよ
感情が 優柔不断だから
感情錯乱だから ぶん殴りたいんだけど
やっぱりまずいと でもぶん殴りたい気持ちやと
それがストレスになるんです
だから相手とうまくいくわけでもないし
きれいさっぱり別れることもしないし
ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃもうなっちゃうんです
それで貪瞋痴悪いということは
なんで世の中貪瞋痴が悪くないと思っちゃうと
この貪瞋痴自体がこの優柔不断状態で感情錯乱状態でいるんだから
大した結果出せてないんです
だから失敗してよかったなんですよ
もし貪瞋痴で成功しちゃうと
もうたまったもんじゃないんですよ
怒りなんか入ったところで
純粋に怒りだけできちんと仕事しちゃうと
もうどうなるかわからないんですよ
だから貪瞋痴はとても危険に決まってるとお釈迦様おっしゃってるんです
でも 俗世間ではそんなこと言われてもね
まあなんか世の中では貪瞋痴なくて生きていられないんだぞとか
くだらんことを言ってるでしょうに
あれは心理学知らないんだから
結局は貪瞋痴が優柔不断状態で
ルーレットみたいに もうなんていうか
感情錯乱状態でごちゃごちゃ回ってるんだから
仕事にならないだけ その子さんみたいに成功したい
もうなんとかいい仕事をしたいと思っちゃえば
あれぐらい成功する それは欲だから殺しにはいかないんです
それであの正しく物事を考えるんだから
金持ちになるためには泥棒しようかなということはなかったんです
では仕事をしましょうということになっただけ
同じ他の人が泥棒しようと思うかもしれません
はい 次 それで同じ法則使ってまして
軍事訓練の場合は殺意とその技
しか教えないんですよ
でないと気持ちが曖昧でも役に立たなくなっちゃうんです
殺せ このように殺せ それしか教えてないんです
助かることもする兵士は勲章はもらえません
たまに戦場で誰か敵とか誰か助かる人を助けてあげる兵士もいますけど
勲章はもらえません 残酷に進んで自分の仕事をこなした人には
もう胸いっぱい勲章で
もう胸も足らなくなって
もう両腕にもつけるんです
だからそのやり方 俗世間でも結構使ってます
そこでマスコミを見たら
自分たちの主義で人々を洗脳するために事実のすべてを報道しないでしょう
この中立といいながら
事実そのまま報道しているんだけど
一部カットするんです
事実ねじ曲がることはしません
特に NHK とかが 他のところは結構ねじ曲がっちゃいますけど
NHK はそのまま事実を伝えますよ
しかし カットするんです
結構ずる賢いやり方なんです
でないと自分言いたいこと言えなくなっちゃうんです
それで日本で軍隊を送りたいってこともはっきり決まってるんだから
あの NTV ともう NHK で流してる場面では同じ場面なんです
イラクの日本人はもう歓迎するんだという一つの看板と
毎日同じ人の何人写真
ビデオを切り取って そればっかり流れて流してるんです
全体的にあれを見せませんし
新しいものを撮っても出せないんです
それでまんまと騙されるんです
やっぱり日本人の期待しているんだと
日本人隊来るということは
日本人に対しては怒りはないということは事実だと思います
イラクは日本人は敵だと見てないんですが
軍鉄砲を持っていくということは
他人の国でね 占領者であることは明らかでしょうし
そうするともう どうしようもないんです
その時警備やってる人を殺すんだからね
そこは日本人であろうと韓国人であろうが
エジプト人と関係ないんですよ
そうしちゃうと 日本の軍隊も鉄砲を持っているのは
もう敵から自分が占領者を守るためでしょ
やらなくちゃいけない
撃ち返さなくちゃいけない
だからその場面ははっきりして知ってますが
やっぱりそれやりたいんだから
もうみんなまあ決まってる報道しか伝えません
しかし 嘘を言ってるわけじゃないんです
不戦のあのあれ 像を倒したこと確かですけど
そこでみんなすごく喜んでいた
それ何人かが集めてもらった人々をちゃんと喜んであげたんです
それは事実です それで我々には間接的にイラン国民がみんな舞い上がって喜んだぞというイメージを作るんで
このカメラアングルだけで
カメラをちょっと変えると別なストーリー
それは言わないという
だから事実をカットする
クリッピングする それに言い訳があります
そんな延々と時間ないんだと
10 分ですと 全部特別番組にしたっても
これはもうまあ 55 分で終わらなくちゃいけない
それでタイトルがあって
出演する人々の紹介があって
お互いのディスカッションであったりすると
ニュースではもう大体まあ 23 分しか取れませんということで
撮ったビデオはもう 8時間ぐらいのものでありますと
それから 23 分取らなく選ばなくちゃいけないのではないかと
あんた方は白って何言うんでしょうかと言い立ててるんです
で それで政治家も自分の計画を実行するために必要なことしか国民に言わない
国民にいらん感情 いらん考え方は作らないことにする
で 結果として必要な感情しか現れないのです
それでやられてますよ
みんな  やられる時はちゃんと法律的にやられますけど
法律ではなくて心理学的にやられますけど
自分で仕事をする時はなんで感情が曖昧で優柔不断で精神錯乱状態なのかと
人間というのは悪いことをする時は見事にやるんですよ
いいことになるともう頭がもうパニック状態なんです
まあはい 続き この行為に必要な感情を行為ごとに理解すれば
自分で成功を収めることはできる
行為ごとに この行為にはこれぐらい感情で十分
この行為にはこれぐらい感情十分と
そうやって行為ごとに感情を理解すればいいんですよ
これがアビダンマでは心所の組み合わせという説明されています
ちょっと文字が間違ってますけど
心所の組み合わせ この子の心所は一緒に行動すると教えているんです
しかし この心所は逆ですよと
一緒にならないんだと
感情錯乱の人は回転させちゃうんですね
そうすると力がなくなるんです
この心所はサポートするんだと
この心所はただ重荷になるだけだと
だから行為をするためには
行為によってこれこれこれと説明あります
しかし それは悪を制し
善を行い 悟りを開くための心理学ですので
儲かるためにどうすればと聞く人には面白くないでしょう
だから世間聞きたいのは
聞きたいのは儲かるためにどんな気持ちでっていう話でしょうね
仏教では心所の組み合わせを説明してますけど
それはまあ善悪の世界のために説明してるんですから
でもわかればすごい役に立ちます
仏教には 俗世間には もうまあ
ラーメンはどのように売れば儲かるかっていう話はする興味はないんだから
人間はどうすれば悪をやめてくれるか
どうすれば人間に善行為をできるのか
どうすれば心が悟りまで進むかということは
仏教のもう何て言いますか
メインテーマだから それからはそらしません
たまたま聞かれるという
家を守るためにどうすればいいかという質問されると説明する
でないと言わない 優柔不断ではありません
はっきりと幸福の道ということは決まっているんです
仏教は で 次にいきます
盗んだり殺したりする生き方ではないから
意外に簡単 ストレスのない
何でしたっけ？日常生活のために
これからもう結論です
我々はどのようにストレスのない日常生活すればいいのかと
皆様もストレス一かけらもない生き方したいでしょう
これが意外と簡単です
なぜならば 皆様一人も盗みたいと思ってないでしょ？人殺したいと思ってないでしょ
それだったら私はいろいろややこしい方法を教えなくちゃいけないんだから
税金ごまかしたいとかね
で どこかで人の土地を奪いたいって
その気持ちないでしょうに
だから毎日ごく普通に仕事をして
料理ご飯作って みんなと仲良くストレスない人生したい
会社でリストラになりたくない
まあそれぐらいのことだから
これが意外と簡単 毎日馬鹿にでもできるシンプルな行為して生きているのです
これを理解してください
会社の社長であろうとも
毎日実際にやっていることは
具体的にやっていることはとてもシンプルですよ
馬鹿にでもできるシンプルなことなんです
だから感情錯乱状態だから責任重大だとか思っちゃうんです
一応我々は たとえ会社の社長であろうとも
実際やっていることはシンプルです
電話かけるとかね 他の会社から来た人とちょっと話して商談を話してみるとかね
部下の仕事をチェックするとかね
すごいシンプルですよ
だからこれ この言葉 このままで覚えておいてください
私は毎日やっていることは馬鹿にでもできるシンプルなことですと
これはもう頭の中にもうもうもう放っておいてください
それでもうストレスなくなるんです
ですから 行動に必要な共通感情だけでだけあれば十分なのです
あの前書いた怒りとか欲とかいらん
共通感情を書いたんですよ
前説明しましたからね
やる気 意志 ちょっとした集中力
こんなのはジャガイモを剥く時でもあるでしょうに
やる気がなければジャガイモも剥けないんだから
これちゃんとジャガイモと包丁の動きに集中しないと剥けないでしょうに
だからそれぐらいの感情で見事に成功して生きていられます
それまた書いてます 意欲
意志 落ち着き 少々の理解
それも私は少々にしたんです
もののことを理解してやると
それは大胆なこといいんです
少々の理解 それから行為に対する喜び
これものすごい強調したいんです
行為に対する喜び このジャガイモを剥くことに喜びを感じてほしい
結果に対する喜びではありません
だからこれ みんな失敗する
結果に結果を重視する
決して結果を重視しないでください
プロセスを重視してください
だから私たちは日常生活の中で綺麗にジャガイモを剥くことではなくて
剥くそのプロセスを楽しむんです
それ楽しむと当たり前
もう綺麗に剥いてますよ
そんなことに喜んじゃうと
次の仕事どうするんですかね
ああ 綺麗に剥いた よくできましたとか
これ自己自賛しちゃうと
次に玉ねぎ切らなきゃいけないんだから
そんな暇がないんだから玉ねぎ切れとやうんです
だから その玉ねぎを切るプロセスを楽しんでやると
ずっと楽しいんです これがストレスない人生の生き方なんです
それでこのそうやって生きてるんですけど
怒り 欲 怒り 怠け等が絡むとストレスになっちゃうんです
だからこんな暇がなくて
すごく明るく プロセスだけ楽しみながら
バカにもできる仕事をしてください
バカにもできる仕事をできないと言っちゃうと
もう恥ずかしいももういいところでしょうに
誰でもやっていることはバカにでもできる仕事なんです
それがいろんな言葉で言ってます
自我を捨てろとか 無心になれとか
よく聞かれてる言葉でしょ
それから私はよく言うことは妄想を控えるとかね
妄想自体は貪瞋痴なんですよ
で 控えようというのもやめろということなんですけど
やめられなきゃったらもう強烈に控えればいいんです
すっごく軽くなるんです
それから日々是好日という言葉があるでしょ
え？日々是好日 これはもういらんだから入れてないんです
で 日々は日々是好日という有名な禅の諺がある
言葉があるんですよ それも同じこと言ってるんですよ
大胆なことじゃないんです
はい もう一つ解消方法があります
これはもう完璧な治療方法で
これではもうこれではもう完治します
ストレスのない日常生活のために
生きる目的 衝動は慈しみっていうことにするんです
であるならば 心に常に必要な感情しか揃わない仕組みになるのです
これがすごい便利ですよ
皆様にアビダンマできなくても
仏教経典読んだことがなくても
アビダンマなんかはもうあれは勉強するもんじゃないんですよ
もうあんまりにもややこしくて
なくても大丈夫です 慈しみはもうもう生きる衝動を目的にすると
常に必要な感情しか揃わないんですよ
だから常に心が糸のままでいるんです
ナイロン糸になってほしいときは
きちんと心がナイロン糸になる
絹の糸になってほしいときは
きちんと絹の糸になる
だからずいぶん便利で楽なんです
これの仕組みはもうもう時間ないんで説明する
ストレスないどころか
失敗に悩みに縁のない人間になります
たった慈悲だけやれば
みんな慈悲にケチつけますでしょうに
これ何言ってるのかと
私にはわからないんです
もう苦しみたいということでしょうね
人を憎んで何がいいんですかね
他人をライバルにしてうまくいくわけないでしょうに
なのに 正直に素直に単純に慈悲をしないんです
それでも哲学聞くんで
哲学はない ただ単なる慈悲
あれ 犬がやってること
それができないんですかね
犬はどうですかね 尻尾振ってくれるでしょうに
抱っこしてあげるとすっごく喜んで胸を舐めてくれるでしょうに
それが慈悲ということなんです
犬にあって人間にないんだから
これになんでやらなくちゃいかんかとか
説明もっと説明欲しいとかね
何言うかわからない 私も
だから今日ははっきり言います
あれ 犬がやってるんです
だから何のこともなく人間に見事に飼われているんです
だから人間っていうのは
自分の親戚が死んでも親が死んでも泣かないんだけど
飼ってる犬が死んじゃうと結構泣いて落ち込むんです
だから犬の勝ちなんです
それぐらい単純なことですよ
すべての生命に対して
ちょっと尻尾振ってあげてください
それだけのこと すべてうまくいくんです
慈しみっていうのは で
自分の生き方は常に他人の役に立っているのか
自分と他人も楽しいのか
だから人間の場合はね
犬は尻尾を振っただけで十分ですけど
我々はいろいろなことをやらなくちゃいけないんだから
その時はこれも必要なんです
とチェックを注視しましょう
そのチェックを何やってもこれで楽しいのか
これで何か役に立っているのかと
すごいシンプルですよ
部屋の掃除すると これ自分で楽しいのかと
で これで役に立つのか
立つのは当たり前なんですけど
それだけで慈しみが機能するんです
それで献身的に貢献的になりましょう
他人の喜び幸福は自分の喜び幸福だと思いましょう
恨むんじゃなくて 他人の幸福も
これはこれはまあ楽しいと
自分の幸福として喜ぶということで次に行きます
嫌な人にも 足を引っ張る人にも
悪いことしかできないバカにも
親切に対応する優れた人間を目指す
みんなそこら辺で文句言うんですよ
人に優しくしたいんだけど
嫌な人はダメですよとかね
足を引っ張る人はやっぱり慈悲をしたら
さらに私の足を引っ張るんではないかとか
そんなことはもうけしからな人間いう話で
もう悪いことしかできない人に対しても優しくしましょう
それで私たちは立派な人間になります
優れた人間になります
敵を許すのはバカじゃなくて立派な人なんですよ
敵を潰すのはもう犬猫動物のやり方なんです
それを覚えてほしいんです
無知な世間に引きずら
引きずられるのではなく
慈しみというモットーをモットーの声に従う
大体みんな世間 世間といつでも気になるでしょうに
世間は無知でしょうに
だから世間の意見ではなくて
慈しみの声を聞くんです
それで決まるんです それは優柔不断ないんです
誰が何と言おうと 自分が人に優しくする
それは慈しみ それで終了しますよ
すごい簡単に はい 次のスライドに行きます
はい また別のアプローチもあります
ストレスないということは
落ち着くと落ち着きと集中力 2つ
落ち着きと集中力があるとストレスがないんです
だから 自分に合っている瞑想方法で落ち着きを育ててればそれでもいい
もう完璧な方法です いつでも落ち着いている
なんとか瞑想 何でもいいんです
まあ一応それで私は完璧に全部説明しただけしたんです
で まあ時間なりから残す
やってないのは このストレスは仏教用語で何と言いますかとかね
まあそこら辺は別に ただの知識だけですからね
これ以上は語れないと思います
はい 次のスライドに行きます
これで終わりです ほつれてロープ
なんか間違ってロープ状態になっている心をスマートな糸にして
ストレスのない幸せな人生を縫いましょうと
人生っていうのは縫っていかなくちゃいけないんだからね
そうやってロープでできないんですよ
こういうハート だからまあ針ではできます
え？あれ もつれる なんかわからない
言葉わからなくて電話して聞いたんですよ
あのゴサゴサになった状態を何と言いましょうかと
うん はい 次 はい それで終了いたします
です